I want to try and tackle probably the
hardest question that most of you are
are asking at this point is what do I do
at home with my kids right now and if
you don't have a training in Singapore
mathematics you don't have a training in
classical education there's a lot of
uncertainty with how you might try to
help support your kids learning at this
point as far as trying to continue
what's being done at their school right
you can one of the things the best
things I think you can do is try to
create some continuity for that student
right so that what you're doing at home
is in line with what they're learning at
school and so I won't try to give just a
few ideas of some things you might do at
home that might fall in line with what
the student is is learning at school and
so I want to take us back if you haven't
watched the video on what is classical
mathematics I'm gonna draw heavily on
some of those topics so you might go
take a look at that I really what we
said classical mathematics is this
fusion of the procedural and the
conceptual together as well as the
fusion of student-teacher led in student
driven now there's a couple of things
that are very difficult about this right
what will you do without a real teacher
here right and but I want to give us
some ideas about what you might do at
home to try and fuse some of these
things right try to make to try to still
preserve some of the elements of
classical mathematics on the home front
right try to take advantage to to
leverage some of the things that the
students have already learned and have
already grown accustomed to at your at
your home so I really want to think
through maybe each of these four things
and how you might try to get to simulate
or try to get a vision for how they
might be incorporated all right so I
think probably the easiest one to keep
incorporating is this idea of the
procedural right so a lot of things you
can do here that can help students with
their procedural knowledge right I'm
thinking of math facts I'm thinking of
just sort of anything that's building
building skills right a lot of the
worksheets or problems from the textbook
here are gonna fall under this side of
things where you're really working on
kids processes if your student strolls
with math facts take this as a chance to
say I've got a couple months at home
with my kid I'm gonna give them all
sorts of ways to build math bags we've
got videos on math facts some games you
can play with students you can grab
flashcards you can have them make
flashcards you can do all sorts of
things to learn math facts but that
would be a phenomenal use of time one
would really set them up for success
there are certain curricula out there
that do a really good job of trying to
come up with all sorts of different kind
of math fact ideas for students that you
can really work on on building some of
their procedural fluency that they're
able to kind of think second nature
about these processes rather than having
to re you know count on their fingers
every single time they're doing an
operation so that would be a really
great use of time as a parent to find
some way to work on your kids procedural
fluency but what I don't what I would
encourage you to do is not let it stop
there and not let it say I'm gonna just
do these things I want to think through
about how to think about the concepts
here right and so really what you want
to think through especially with
Singapore mathematics is trying to get
kids engaging in drawing pictures right
and and and go watch the videos about
how to do bar modeling how to do place
value how to do ten frames if you're a
kinder if you have a kindergartener
right how to get them using these ideas
of manipulatives and the other thing
that I'll really that I really encourage
here and it's gonna get a little bit
down into this idea is get students
doing some way to figure out how to
explain the processes that they're doing
as a parent this can be as easy as
coming to a student who's working on
some problem from the textbook and just
having them explain to you what they did
for that problem
it doesn't take any effort at all as a
parent just walk past and say how'd you
do this one and have them walk you
through the concepts that are there you
don't ask any follow-up questions and
their explanations might not map make a
ton of sense right but having getting
just getting them to go through the
conceptual process right getting them to
explain what they're doing and why
they're doing right and just even asking
right why did you do that
in that way right can even get the
student taking some of these processes
and explaining them right ask them how
can we remember what five times six is
all right what's five times six
like is it like five times five what's
different about it and you can just get
them thinking a little bit more
conceptual about some of the facts and
skills building that they're gonna be
challenged to do right if you're a
teacher watching this when you're
sending home a lot of things that are
more skills based see if you can send
home a couple of questions that require
students to reflect a little bit require
students to have a conversation with
their parents right even if you're a
first grader
I'd say teach them a math fact game and
then have them teach it to their parents
right have them explain or even just sad
them write down their strategy or think
about their strategy with their parents
about what they did there right so that
you're taking some of these more Skills
heavy things and incorporating some of
the conceptual questions right don't
lose the conceptual even as we're
shifting into this home school or online
format or it's easy to do these kind of
things and I think we're gonna have find
some ways to have some robust skills
building opportunities which I would
encourage you to do but find some way to
incorporate some of these conceptual
ideas as well whether you're a teacher
or a parent the other thing I want to
think through here is this fusion of
teacher led and student driven right and
parents if you're watching you need to
become this role in the teacher student
idea right
takes two people to actually have a
conversation here and your teachers
can't for the most part have the
conversations and so right just thinking
through some basic questions that you
can ask that you don't need to have any
math knowledge about that are gonna
generate some conversations so if you're
thinking about how what you might you do
at home the main thing is to have
conversations about the mathematics with
your students and that's gonna be the
most classical thing you can do you can
play games with them you can work on
their math facts you can just give them
a chance to work on their own but
whatever you're doing engage them in
some kind of conversation all right
whether they're a kindergartener or a
12th grader find some way to converse
with them right and some basic questions
right just again remembering mathematics
being the art of explanation just ask
them to explain to me what you did why
did you do it that way even just asking
which of these problems was the hardest
and why which was the easiest and why
right and just you know asking students
mean asking students what their
strategies are one of the best moments
I've ever had in classical education was
playing a game of war with a
kindergartner right and war is just easy
you turn over cards and you see which
one's bigger which one's not at the end
of the game I asked this kindergartner
what was your strategy during the game
the game has no strategy right and the
kindergartner basically went for about a
full minute or two listing their
strategies about what they were trying
you know I tried to get a card that was
very close to yours but a little bit
higher you know and when I had a war I
was really trying to get this high card
at the very end and you know it's just
great for them to be explaining those
things you know you've if when you get
students talking about the mathematics
you've already won as a teacher as a
parent right
and so the best thing you can do as a
parent is to really engage in these kind
of conversations with your students it
doesn't really matter what you're doing
right but finding them just to ask some
of these basic questions right the other
big one right that you can try to
incorporate a little bit and I'll end
here right is this idea of what if what
if the number was one larger what if it
was one smaller what if you had this
instead of this what would you do that
just these these cost you nothing here
as a parent you don't have to know
anything you don't to do anything but
you can engage your children in
conversation right you're shifting the
academic community from the classroom
where they're gonna be having these
dynamic conversations with teachers and
classmates right around is meaningful
things and you're shifting that's locus
or that center of Education into the
home right and so don't just turn your
kids loose to do their own math facts
and skills building find some way to
engage them with some kind of
conversation I promise you it will be
well worth your while both for the
students sake and just for the sake of
having good conversations among family